[Music]  lianna's who puts it down a lot of  zippers to get that she hand off and  then draw the second defender Scott  you do for Milwaukee formulas out  Gallinari see hand off and then draw the  second defender Scott and then guys in  bigs in particular stationed around that  three-point line for kick-out  Yanis is back as he is  back before half-time got a tide rogdon  for an easy one into shoot the man he  declines the invitation  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  one more stop  [Music]  [Applause]  how you stop that sells like slippers up  by three holding on so the Clippers up  by three holding on in the Bledsoe  [Applause]  [Music]  go get that ball in Duncan in the class  dojo to the contested Warcraft  terrific defense and not real good  offense  [Applause]  [Music]  1:26